you know it's been popular rod what's
that
our slinky drop video that is popular
isn't it yeah do you want to do another
think you drop that's not a slinky this
is a slinky that is a that is an
excellent slinky we should drop that one
we want to see whether a long slinky and
we're 50 meters up here whether a long
slinky works the same as a short slinky
because some people on YouTube don't
really believe that it's going to work
the same or they want to see it what
path to find out all right I'll go film
it from the grass and now you drop the
slinky thought okay
so you go run you say it yeah
no it's a good drill to get it I don't
know I think so we gotta check the
cameras
well I think it it tended to tumble on
us it got got right down to the bottom I
think it's going too fast and tumbling I
think you'd better we better do that one
again we're going to do it again yeah
all right
ah thanks dude I'm not a problem I saw
that it still tumbles when it gets to
the end yeah it's clear to me that you
wouldn't want to be sitting at the end
of this under an aeroplane no there's
not know much better to actually have a
parachute exactly so what do you think
about the explanations that have been
going around on the web you know people
talking about the center of mass is
falling with the acceleration due to
gravity 9.8 meters per second squared is
that true
uh yes I did and then the bottom end
people are saying it's actually shooting
up to meet the middle is that happening
or what do you think I wasn't the rest
frame it's staying at rare say that need
that explanation and it almost makes the
most sense just to consider in our frame
of reference nothing has changed at the
bottom until the top of this slinky
compresses sure why not just take
gravity out of the equation altogether
and let's see what happens to our
horizontal slinky all right let's have a
look at that okay this was prepared by
Rod earlier when I hit the right-hand
end of the spring the left-hand end
doesn't move until the compression wave
travels down the length of the spring
and changes the tension at that end yeah
so it's about the same thing as the
slinky but obviously there's no
gravitational force involved there
correct cool all right well thanks so
much we have learned a lot about slinkys
my budget